après bonnières sur seine et
mantes-la-jolie c'est au tour de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines d'inaugurer sa
première boutique à l'essai une boutique
de 37 mètres carrés qui propose à des
créateurs de tester leurs idées de
commerce au sein d'une boutique pilote
de six mois le premier axe c'est d'avoir
la commune l'amérique s'ils jouent le
jeu le deuxième axe c'est d'abord la
boutique un local le troisième c'est
d'avoir un porteur de projet et puis le
quatrième c'est de l'accompagnement il a
aidé tout d'abord par pour voir si son
modèle d'affaires son business model
quand on parle en anglais et pérenne est
pertinent par rapport à l'endroit qu'ils
souhaitent s'implanter son type
d'activité suite ya le loyer modéré la
modération des loyers de manière à ce
que la charge ne soit pas trop important
qu'initialement
et puis troisième levier c'est aussi le
prêt à taux zéro les prêts d'honneur un
concept lancé par initiative sa divine
en lien avec rambouillet territoire la
municipalité et le propriétaire nous
souhaitons vraiment car donner une
chance à un nouveau commerçant à
saint-arnoult qui aurait peut-être des
difficultés pour reprendre lui même à
130 boutiques ce qu'il faut c'est qu'ils
soient elles et dès avant de démarrer
et je suis le premier voulant l'aider au
départ au delà du soutien de
l'accompagnement aux porteurs de projets
elle permet également de redynamiser le
centre ville en créant de nouveaux
commerces de proximité cela contribue à
la redynamisation du centre-ville et
nous sommes vraiment
conscient que c'est un effort pour un
commerçant de s'installer et que c'était
des vraiment la bienvenue pour le
territoire nous voulons que que cette
boutique contribuer au dynamisme de
notre commune souvent la ville veut dire
vaccin j'ai peur d'une mercerie tiens
j'ai besoin de de friperie jeu voilà
donc on va pouvoir aussi orientés en
fonction des besoins de la ville alors
si votre projet correspond contacter
initiative saniclean les lauréats
devrait être choisi d'ici la fin du mois
de janvier